[Music]
welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster i'm konstantine kiss this is a
show for you if you're bored of people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about trigonometry we
don't pretend to be the experts we ask
the experts a fantastic expert guest
this week is the former deputy mayor of
London for Education and Culture who now
works in art whenever Mercer
welcome to trigonometry is a journalist
and a researcher at Sheffield University
romeo decoy welcome to trigonometry
amazing expert guest this week is
Brendan O'Neil
who's the editor of spiked online
Brendan welcome to trigonometry thank
you very much he's an Australian
economist the CEO of lateral economics
and the self-styled general pontificate
er nicholas grow and welcome to
trigonometry
tell us a little bit of what's happening
in Australia one of the things we talk
on this show a lot about is the culture
wars and all those kind of stuff where
are you guys with that well I think we
were in a very good place in the 80s and
90s where we led the world in economic
policy and we had a government in fact
there was a bipartisan consensus on
things like race gender and so on and
that broke down as you could you if you
were looking to blame the Labour Party
you would blame Paul Keating because he
was a who was the prime minister from 90
from 1991 to 1996 and he was very
divisive but he was still part of the
bipartisan consensus which didn't go
after culture wars but then on that on
the change of baton to John Howard as
Prime Minister it's kind of he famously
was very insightful in revving up what
seems to have been lightened in the
Australian psyche which is that if if
white Rhodesian farmers were boat people
floating off our coast I'm sure we would
have wanted to save them but if they had
brown people from the Middle East or
Asia not so much
and so we've slid into a pretty
unpleasant state of affairs where you
know we're we're well we keeping keeping
people out now of course we have to keep
people out there are 60 million refugees
who not all of which could come to
Australia but it's appropriate that we
don't just say any old any old person
can come in here but the lengths that
we've gone to India humanizing people is
is national is a national shame and most
people feel it but there we are
it wins elections and neither of the
major parties a bit like brexit where
the elites sort of kind of appreciate it
might not be the greatest policy they
think that the people will crucify them
if they move away
their policy so we've got something
similar going on in Australia and do you
think that that policy has been brought
about because of racism or do you think
it's brought about through other things
as well like we've had one particular
guest on who you know who was saying you
know there is because they want to keep
the reason we voted for brexit is
because we want to beat British culture
intact do you think that is what's going
on in Australia or do you think it's
more of simply that disturbing for you
answer that sorry Francis that interview
will come out after this one so Francis
has given you a tasty preview of a
interview with Eric Cartman who'll be
our in a couple of that's what I like
about you is just that I'm a believer in
presumptive generosity when you're
interpreting people it makes sense to
try and interpret that you're trying to
make as much sense of what they're
saying and doing in the way they're
acting as possible and it's a perfectly
legitimate that it's a perfectly
legitimate thing to say that we've built
a great society here certainly better
than many societies around the world and
we want to protect that so so I don't
have any people who feel anxious that
too many migrants are coming in from
very different cultures I don't feel
that way but I don't demonize that I
don't demonize that at all and then
there were some racists then there was
some very small minded bigoted racists
but I don't that that's not the way I
look at the debate in Australia or
anywhere else really do you think it's
cultural essentially it's cultural and
it's perfectly legitimate to say we say
as the Japanese say we are proud of our
culture and it's not compatible with too
many people coming in here because then
it'll be a different culture I think
people underestimate that they
underestimate the extent to which our
culture can remain can protect the best
parts of it and then become more
exciting we have a commentator in
Australia called Philip Adams who I
think his line is that we invited a lot
of European migrants into Australia and
found that was so much fun
we wanted more so so that's my attitude
to immigration but but you know I'm not
an open I'm not I'm not an open door
policy person either I'm in favor of her
of a vigorous and expansive immigration
program for Australia and I respect
people who want to I don't I don't hold
up the cross and say you're a racist if
people feel differently so your concern
is how those refugees are treated
essentially on well I don't want to
preserve one of my concerns our
self-righteousness so it's very
important for me not to be
self-righteous about this because I'm a
privileged person who's going to say to
a desperate person sorry you're not
coming
and whether I draw that line at two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
four hundred thousand a million a year
and at the moment it's something like
two hundred thousand a year I'm gonna be
just as much of a bastard as anyone else
so let's get off our high horses let's
try and make ourselves as comfortable as
we can be with the policy whatever
policy we come up with and we will be
making heartless and cruel decisions
nevertheless let's make them as let's
minimize that unless feel as good as we
can about it and locking up little kids
on on Islands off off off Australia
without any judicial review that's
there's nothing good about that doesn't
make people feel good
I mean numerous people have died who
needed medical attention and didn't get
it
I raised $10,000 for Refugees at a party
about a month ago and a great writer of
ours Christos sulcus read the names of
those people so I feel very strongly
about this
I don't feel self-righteous about it and
there's a big difference
my father was a refugee so that's
another reason I feel strongly about it
so do you think the Australian
government atheistic intimacies is
unnecessarily cruel in their treatment
of retitling well what would you do if
you have my view or anybody else's view
and you know that there's a kid on Manus
Island who's self-harming who has
pneumonia
who needs medical attention and you say
are well they might be they might be
pulling our leg they might be pulling a
stunt they probably are pulling a stunt
okay but they need medical attention and
we should be giving the medical
attention and we're not whenever I watch
Australian comedian a comedy club the
first joke they make is about Australia
being a racist society and it always
gets a big laugh and everybody claps and
cheers is that true boys or would you
show all races so I mean you know these
tests on basketball umpires you know I
have a friend I just had I just had cup
of tea with a friend who he's a Dutchman
and he organised he was instrumental in
organizing an experiment on busses where
people got onto a bus and said to the
bus driver I'm really sorry I don't have
any money I just need to get to the next
stop would you mind me writing to the
next stop
alright now these numbers are made up
but they're indicative so just assume
they're right for the for the purposes
the seventy one or two percent of people
had yes said to them sorry about 65
percent but if you were white it was
much higher if you were black it was
lower and those bus drivers I don't
think they were black hating racists but
so let's let's relax about these things
let's get let's not get too much on a
high
truther may announce when she became
Prime Minister that she was going to
attack all burning in justices in
society and one of the and now it's
virtually made was that the government
would run something called a racial
disparities order so it would look at
how different ethnic groups fare in
British society in the public services
so the NHS and health and education but
also know about employment and other
kinds of discrimination policing
criminal justice system and so on and
the report was published last year or
the website was launched that showed
these statistics and interestingly the
the audit revealed that the pic was very
complex it's it's not clear-cut that
white people always do better and I
think minorities always do worse in fact
there is some areas where I think
mothers are doing really well so if you
look at the NHS for instance about a
third of doctors in the NHS or DME the
non-white or third of senior consultants
in the NHS are normalize so there are
some areas where actually there's a real
success story or something celebrates
but when the audit was published all the
emphasis from government and from the
media was on the negatives where I think
Morrissey's are not doing well and it
perpetuated what I thought was a very
negative inaccurate picture really of
British society you know it reinforces
this idea that I think minorities are
being systematically oppressed that
there's a kind of institutional problem
when in fact what we've seen in the last
20 years is a kind of liberalisation and
opening up for many people and my worry
has always been that when you tell that
negative story it both you know it's you
as policy it means that people make bad
policy decision because they think
they're trying to correct something
that's actually working quite well but
it also reinforces for a lot of younger
people this idea that they can't succeed
and that I think can have quite a big
material impact it can mean that they're
not motivated to go out apply to
university go and be ambitious seek good
jobs because they'll think that they've
always got a kind of white racist
decision-maker who's holding them back
and I think that can create a lot of
tension and division in this society if
you're constantly telling people from
ethnic background
that the versus Isis against you that's
not going to be great for engineering
harmonious social relations you know
they're gonna be resentful have you've
made the point even further actually
that for example a black defendant who's
suspicious about his lawyer is more
likely to make a bad decision for
example to plead innocent when in fact
they should plead guilty and as a result
of that you end up with young black men
getting harsher sentences yeah
because they don't trust the system and
they don't do that what they ought to do
kind of in a percentage place situation
yeah the criminal justice system report
which was authored by or led by David
Lam EMP showed that there was this
disparity I mean in many other areas
many of the parts that kernel justice
system the the disparity between ethnic
groups can be explained by a number of
different factors the fact that there
are you know proportionally a higher
number of black men in in the criminal
justice system is is you know there are
reasons for that you know there are
higher proportions of arrests you know
the the you know you can go into the
detail of that there was one disparity
which was interesting in that report
which is why is it that black men are
more likely to receive harsh sentencing
and they found interestingly as you say
that that they were not pleading guilty
because they didn't trust the advice of
their solicitors and they didn't trust
the system and that's a I think I would
argue is partly result of not completely
but it's poly result of their fear that
the system is going to be prejudiced
against them so it has this really
counterproductive effect it's you know
damaging to their life chances really
and the same things happened in other
areas like mental health for instance
where we know that there's been a huge
amount of debate and discussion about
whether the institutional there's
institutional racism in the mental
health system because a higher
proportion of ethnic minorities are
likely to appear in the system and to be
detained forcibly detained
there's obviously worrying when you look
at the statistics anything why is it you
know they more likely to have mental
illness yes they are actually you know
there's lots of good research to show
that there for all sorts of reasons they
have higher risk factors but also what
they what researchers have found is that
a lot of people from ethnic groups are
worried about
how the system is going to treat them so
they don't report until it's almost too
late until their their condition has
worsened to a point where they may end
up being violent to themselves or other
people and at that point they need to be
forcibly detained at that point the
police get involved and and you have a
very different the system has to react
differently to you so I the thing that
frustrates me is that people use these
statistics almost with the political
agenda to try and prove a point about
systemic racism but the effects of that
is even more damaging and if we were
more honest if we were looking the
statistics more dispassionately you
would see that it's just a really
complex picture and and I think I see my
ortiz are you know the ones who suffer
the most often you know because no one's
really thinking about their interests as
you know as individuals in the system
they're just thinking how can we make a
political point how can we show that
we're virtuous you know I think in the
in the city in the case of the
government I think the government was
trying very hard to show that it wasn't
the nasty party anymore that you know
they care about these vulnerable groups
but in doing that they you know they
have perpetuated a lot of these
perceptions and this very negative story
you say something really loud we keep
telling you to Kaname tree that no one
wants us to be having these comments on
there's a [ __ ] helicopter hovering
above us by the way we forgot to explain
in the beginning of the interview that
we are location as we told you last week
and we're one of our big fans it's
equally true just above yeah there's a
helicopter hovering above us just
recording everything and reporting us to
the police for hate crime yeah we're
gonna have to make a run for it yeah and
as me as the white man I'm gonna give up
scot-free typical exactly but there's
one thing that we didn't cover when we
look at these stats and I as a former
teacher I do find it incredibly
interesting is working white
working-class boys all we're always at
the bottom when it comes to stats and I
sometimes think that if it had been you
know working class black boys working
for us asian boys there would be a
massive outcry about it rightly so but
because it's working-class white boys we
tend to stick struggler so doesn't go oh
what can you do let's crack on and they
do tend to be forgotten almost yeah I
think I think that has changed actually
I mean in the last few years there's
been more awareness of the fact that
it's not just it's not it's not just a
racial thing yeah and and what we don't
want to get into is this idea that
somehow white working-class boys are
being failed because of their whiteness
either you know there are problems with
our education system actually I think
what's happening is that a lot of
immigrant families are correcting and
are intervening and are you know getting
their kids to go to private tutors to
correct for faults in the system and you
know it's not unusual if you're going
you know if you're driving around South
London you will see in shop windows
adverse for maths and English tuition
for immigrant groups you know there are
Saturday schools there's a very strong
culture of supplementary schools in the
afro-caribbean community for instance
these are all to try and correct for
what they perceive to be problems in the
education system and that hasn't been
the case for a lot of white
working-class communities but yeah you
know we have to I think we should focus
our education system on you know
supporting the people who are struggling
whatever their ethnic background and so
for too long we've racialized a lot
these problems this is the pointman
areas like what Francis questions
reveals under your answer is that we
think in terms of race all the time now
and this way of thinking encourages
white people to think about well well if
you're talking about these ethnic
minorities what about us we're
victimizing this area and it's just like
and even if you don't agree with it as I
don't I was driving home the other day
and there was a girl waiting to cross
the road and it was like one of those
choice situations I could have driven or
I could have let her pass and I swear to
God I looked her and she was black and I
went what she's black I gotta let us
through you know this is how we start to
think and it's crazy isn't it
this is absolutely mental that we've
been encouraged to think in this way I
don't for not being racist even laughing
about it
yeah I think people change their
behavior and they're on guard the
sensitivity about it and you know the
end result is that you end up treating
people differently because their race
and they know it so
I remember I think I may have said it
even at the Battle of idea session those
that that there was one writer I won't
name as she wrote a blog he complained
that white people would come up to her
and say how articulate she was and she
felt that this was an insult because
really they weren't expecting her to be
articulate because she's a black female
and I thought you know even when when
compliments are treated as some kind of
expression of racism you know whoa
there's literally nothing you can do
everything you say and it could be that
they just thought she genuinely was
articulate and they were congratulating
her for it but people then become very
defensive and afraid I remember reading
a report a long time ago it was a I
think it was in the it was a report of
the Met Police I'm about ten years ago
and they noted that but black police
officers were more likely to be formally
disciplined than white police officers
in the Met and there was a discussion of
the paper about you know what was the
driver behind this and it turns out one
of the reasons is because their
superiors were so worried about having
informal conversations with them about
problems that they felt they had to go
through the formal means and that's what
happens we don't trust our instincts we
don't trust how people will perceive
that we don't think that they will give
us the benefit of the doubt so we do
everything in a much more formally
formally regulated way so in the
workplace people are afraid of
interacting with their colleagues in a
particular way you know the words said
incorrectly or a slightly insensitive
remark you know where do you come from
that kind of thing is now regarded as
racism could get you discipline you
could end up in a racial grievance
situation you know the workplace is a
you know essentially it's still a
workplace you know you have a boss who
they have the power to sack you
so the kind of informal social
relationships that you need to be
healthy an order for a civic society to
be strong or being weakened by you know
people's you know kind of desperation to
jump on so anything as being potentially
offensive
you wrote an article for Quiller which I
think got a lot of people's attention
including ours and for anyone who hasn't
read it we'll put it in in the in the
YouTube below but tell us a little what
about what was the kind of the gist the
crux of your article for anyone who
hasn't seen it
well the crux of the article was
essentially based on a conversation
essentially I had with a friend of mine
a back friend of mine and it was about
how we discuss race when I say we I mean
black people in public and in private
and how there's a big difference usually
and there are calculations which are
made regarding what we should say in
public and what we shouldn't say in
public these calculations are
essentially based on how many black
people view our interests
so essentially I'd say maybe on
self-preservation instincts like I wrote
in the article about how ok I was
talking to this friend of mine and he
was complaining about black friend of
his at the workplace who sort of you
know plays the race card anytime there's
a there's a difficult situation with a
white person yeah
the friend is like friend of my friend
is like oh you know bring out the race
card and most likely ninety-nine percent
of the time a white person will back
down so my friend told me oh he finds
this disgusting doesn't like it this is
completely wrong etc and in this
conversation we were having
I said yeah exactly so that's why we
have to start criticizing this you know
black identity Rian's and people sort of
you know trying to essentially leverage
some of the horrors which ancestors went
through for some form of advantage today
ok then my friend said well actually I
don't agree with you on that you know
and I'm like you know why but you just
said now that you don't like people
leveraging leveraging race like this and
he says yeah but actually if you look at
the big picture you'll find out that
look he says look let's think about it
how many of those black people are there
here in the UK ok about 5% of the
population do we have a lot of economic
and political power
no we don't okay that's the reality
what is actually preventing the white
population about 87% who control almost
all the political and economic power
from actually dominating us overtly my
friend asked me the only thing that's
stopping them from doing that is the
fear of being called racists yeah it's
political correctness is the restraint
which has been placed on them by society
regarding how they should talk to
minorities yeah and he says that's the
only saving grace we actually have and
he says take that away and what do we
have take that away and we could have a
situation like we had in the 70s and the
80s okay where people on the road you
know using the n-word freely and don't
feel afraid to do that because there's
you know no social ostracism no social
consequences from doing that so they're
gonna people are gonna be doing it and
he's like what was interesting here my
friend who is a very intelligent guy
very successful banking city in London I
said it's not because you know why
people are evil or something like that
but he said that's simply human nature
if you put people in a position of
dominance over another group of people
and they're not checks okay they are
going to abuse that position so his
argument is essentially then you need
white guilt to protect minorities yes
that without white guilt we'd be in a
much more difficult situation here and
essentially you know white people sort
of wouldn't have any restraints towards
you know talking to us anyhow or using
exploiting that advantage which they do
have over us in numbers in political
power in economic power etc so he's like
you know that's the only restraint so he
sees that as a sort of necessary evil
he's like I don't like it
aesthetically morally I don't really
like it but I think we need it you know
in order to protect ourselves cause it's
all we've got
if we let go of that if we black people
start criticizing identity politics
black identity Rian's then and
mainstream white society says well you
know since it seems that if a black
people don't agree with his identity
reans then you know maybe why bother
with this whole you know political
correctness thing and he's like looking
at that in the long term it's actually
going to be bad for us and what do you
make of that argument Sir Francis look
that argument
I'd be lying if I told you that argument
I was like oh that's rubbish it's an
argument which made me think I actually
you know started imagine imagining
certain scenarios I started actually
thinking okay fine what if tomorrow now
you know political correctness was
simply you know dubbed unnecessary by
mainstream white society because there's
obviously already a segment of society
which says it's rubbish
but I'm talking of mainstream majority
sixty seventy percent of the people what
if they actually said postcard lightness
is rubbish actually we should be able to
say anything we like more or less two
black people etc would that be a more
pleasant environment for me to live in
being a minority here in numbers I can't
imagine it being yeah it's that way to
be the case if it were to go in that
direction that people would want to
exploit that advantage so like I said I
couldn't I definitely didn't you know
think what my friend was saying was
rubbish but I thought about it and the
thing is you know maybe it's I don't
know maybe it's naive or something but
based on my experiences with especially
people here in the UK because I've had
different experiences also in Poland
that's a different kettle of fish but
based on my experience with people here
in the UK I do believe fundamentally
that a majority of the white population
here does not have racist instincts and
would not exploit to their advantage
yeah if you know the whole race thing
and the numbers advantage they have and
the particular advantage they have if
say political correctness theoretically
was to disappear that's what I believe
that there's a fundamental decency in
most people who live here I believe that
two three hundred percent based on
experiences which I've had based on
experiences a mitral Nigerian work life
is 100 percent Nigerian she's actually
lived in the UK bit longer than me
counting and intervals and all that and
based on her experience also you know
based on things we talked about based on
experiences of some other people when we
actually sit down and talk because you
know sometimes black people may complain
about racism here but you know when we
sit down when I say we when we black
people sit down in the room you know and
I'm like guys come on you know these
people really
they're actually pretty tolerant like
yeah yeah of course we know you know but
you know we can't we shouldn't sort of
say that out we sort of have to keep up
that moral pressure yeah just to make
sure they don't want be taken into their
heads to start exploiting those
advantages of us and fitness DVD should
features twenty thirty years ago so it's
not like people don't know this it's not
like a lot of people who might even you
know retweet and the black identity runs
you know for lack of a better term post
on Twitter saying maybe not the most
radical ones but let's just see
something sort of insinuating that is a
lot of racism and in the UK it's not
like every black person who reads which
that actually really believes it's that
bad okay but it's just part of you know
keeping up this pressure and part of you
know trying to sort of a message protect
ourselves from this white power which a
lot of people actually fear you know and
as I argued in the in the piece that's
historical reasons of course for that
fear but doesn't the rise of something
of someone like Trump in the u.s. yeah I
mean that their fears actually
well-founded because although obviously
I'm not black I'm half Latin American
and when Trump came out and did the
speech and talked about Mexicans and
said immigrants some of them are racist
no summer summer sort of a rapist
immediately I had a sinking sensation
inside and if I went to the US in
certain areas I wouldn't feel
comfortable speaking Spanish which is my
second language hmm
of course and you know there's no
pretending I know we'd be silly to
pretend here that is you know no such
thing as racism oh it's a very you know
marginal thing which you know only 5% of
the white population you know and
subscribe to and all that no that's not
the way it is is something which is very
real and exists among more than five or
ten percent of the white population in
standard let's say Western society so of
course that exists and Trump
paradoxically has only strengthened you
know identity politics among minority
minority sort of intellectuals because
there
see we told you guys you guys were
saying these white people you know that
I'm a they are not that racist they're
not that bad etc now do you see look who
they voted for they voted for a guy who
said all the things he said so even the
black people before I focus on black
that's the community I know the other
minority groups even the black people
before who were sort of neutral or
didn't buy into those narratives that oh
essentially every second white person is
racist you know sort of now feel
sometimes a little bit silly thinking
actually I was naive yeah it seems this
white folk are really pretty racist I
mean they did vote for this Trump guy
who said all those things so you know
maybe I was the one who was naive and
not these identity politics guys yeah
maybe they were the ones who are right
yeah and there's some others who say
yeah well of course you know Trump
doesn't represent all white people etc
etc but since there is such a political
force right now we definitely need to
stand on the side of our people okay and
defend our people who are being attacked
by this kind of politics so even if we
don't agree ninety or much less 100
percent with the black identity Rian's
we definitely need to hold the line with
them because you know these are the guys
fighting for us definitely Trump is not
fighting for us and the people who
support Trump but everything is not
fighting for us okay so it's sort of
it's it's bad for people like me but
it's a strong word it's difficult for
people like me because now there's a
line drawn yeah so it's a you know are
you with them or are you with us okay
are you with the Trump folk who are
saying the things they're saying or are
you with us who are trying to you know
sort of resist the Trump folk you know
so it's it's tricky right now
[Music]
you just wrote a color recently caught a
column about how white guilt is
essentially become a perverse way of
signaling your virtue and it's becoming
almost white pride and wicked yeah
sounds very counterintuitive what do you
mean by that
yeah it's all these people who are
constantly checking their white
privilege and you know they go online
they go on Twitter they go on Facebook
or they write articles and they say I'm
white I have to recognize that I'm a
very privileged person and I shouldn't
speak over black people I shouldn't
speak over women and so on and I've been
watching this go on for a few years now
and I was thinking it's really strange
because it's it looks shameful you know
they're very ashamed of being white
they're very ashamed of what they call
white History and colonialism and Empire
and everything else so they express this
great shame but they do it in such a
showy narcissistic ostentatious way look
at me I'm so ashamed
and what you realize is that actually
there's a real boastfulness to this
checking of your white privilege and
they're really making a public display
of it so I think what's going on here is
that this expression of white shame or
this expression of white guilt has
really become a new form of white pride
because in essence what they're saying
is we are good white people we're very
socially and politically aware was
switched on we're sensitive to the
crimes of history we're sensitive to the
needs and interests of black people
we're good whites not like those
otherwise the uneducated ones the
uncouth ones the ones who didn't go to
Oxford University the ones who don't
read The Guardian and the ones who don't
use Twitter they're the bad whites so
what you see is they're creating almost
this new white nationalism ironically
where they are demonstrating their
decent whiteness in contrast largely to
bad white people so it's a very racially
driven form of narcissism I think this
checking of your white privilege it's
also so not only does it do mean bad
whites
I think implicitly means bad words it
also demeans black people because it's
driven by this idea that black people
are quite fragile and therefore there
are certain things you shouldn't say in
their presence or there are certain
things that we maybe shouldn't publish
or there are certain
because we shouldn't invite to campus
because black people would disappear
into a crisis of self-esteem which i
think is also a very racially driven
denigrated view of black people so I
think this idea that whiteness is this
all-powerful thing and it can even
induce trauma in people because you know
whiteness is this powerful force
actually what that says is that white
people are very strong and black people
who might crumble if you say something
racist or my crumble if you invite Tommy
Robinson to your campus are very weak so
it actually rehabilitates this
politically correct white guilt which is
now incredibly fashionable actually
recreates the idea that whites are the
adults with great power to cause
distress and blacks are the children who
might sometimes need censorship and
other things to protect them from
offensive ideas I find it really
repugnant and that's one of the examples
of how identity politics we when you
think Hyper racially all the time you
end up rehabilitating racial stereotypes
in this case that whites are all
powerful and blacks are weak and that's
where this identity politics is taking
us it's taking us down a very dark alley
towards the old racist politics that so
many of us spend a lot of time trying to
escape and or to defeat so what do you
make of the concept of white privilege
in general then I think it's [ __ ] I
think it's it expresses a very infantile
way of understanding society and the
dynamics within society do I think
there's racism of course I also think
racism is far rarer now than it was in
the past I think it's become this
minority pursuit among pockets of people
whereas in the past and even I'm old
enough to remember this it was a fairly
dominant ideology in Western societies I
think that's faded away and that's all
to the good but racism yes racism still
exists but whatever it isn't about
racism Sarita's right it's not about
racism it's the idea that you and I
walking down the street will be treated
differently to to black people walking
down the street by other people by shop
assistants by the police by whatever
that's the idea yeah but that's not
necessarily true but
the reason I think it's a very narrow
way to understand societies because I
think you're far greater influence on
people's fortunes is class and that's
how I think is a far better way to
understand society so the idea that you
know people say privileged white men
privileged white this privileged white
that the vast majority of white people
don't have don't enjoy any form of
privilege and are actually quite poor or
working-class the majority of them and
the idea of white privilege is actually
one that comes from a very privileged
strata of society which is academia and
professors and young people who brought
up in very middle-class homes to go off
to university and come up with these
theories about white privilege so it's
this very bizarre twisted ridiculous
idea that you know these like those
black kids are Oxford who are the all
there on Rhodes Scholarships so they
come from incredibly privileged
backgrounds and they're on Rhodes
Scholarships at Oxford the finest
university in the world and they spend
the whole time going on about how
privileged white people are what
including the the Polish white man who
who built the extension to your house or
I don't know the the Turkish white man
who cleans your toilet what are we
talking about here there's a real
unwillingness to understand the
complexities of modern society and the
fact that in my view class remains the
deciding factor as to your fortunes and
where you're going and how successful
you can be you know this was really
brought home by there's a trans there's
a black trans woman called Monroe
Bergdorf and she gave an interview to
The Guardian recently because she got in
trouble because she said all white
people are racist and she gave an
interview to The Guardian and she was
explaining her concept of white
privilege and she said even a homeless
white man has privilege and the
justification she gave was that in
comparison with a homeless black man
he's got more chance of getting out and
she didn't provide any statistics for
that or anything like that but the point
is she came she comes from an incredibly
privileged background her mother was
very successful in business she had a
lovely upbringing she now has a very
lovely life and she is telling the man
who lives under a bridge and is addicted
to heroin
and might starve to death any moment now
that he enjoys privilege that's how
screwed up identity politics has become
and I think identity politics
increasingly looks like the Revenge of
the elite and and it's a way for them to
to fly in the face of all the evidence
and to argue that they are the victims
they are the great victims of life
because you know if the white man who's
living in a skip has more privileged
than they do it's utterly surreal I
don't think it's sustainable and I think
it's a very again it's very poisonous
argument because it divided society
along racial lines when in fact I think
the key divide in societies is still a
matters of wealth and class that's very
very interesting how you pointed that
out to me I think that identity politics
is actually a great one the greatest
dangers to freedom of speech in that
people are willing to engage in debate
because what people now do is they don't
are you put forward that argument but I
know there is a counter-argument to that
which would just be well as a white man
yeah you're not entitled to those views
or opinions simply because you've never
experienced the struggle in inverted
commas and therefore completely
denigrating your argument instead of
actually engaging with the argument and
putting forward a counter counter point
of view which is entirely reasonable
it's simply to attack the person
speaking and the moment you do that I
think they're all semblance of
discussion and freedom of speech it just
goes out the window is dead yeah it's
terrible because people's ideas and
views are judged on the basis of their
skin color and all their genitals or
whatever it might be rather than on what
they're actually saying which cat runs
counter to every democratic liberal
ideal which is that you should hear
people out have the discussion have an
open discussion and then work out as a
society what's good and what's bad and
where we should go and so on so it runs
I completely agree is completely
destructive for freedom of speech and
open debate and what it does it really
causes people to clam up
so people feel that there are certain
things they shouldn't say in public or
and lots of when I go to campuses and so
on there's often white men who just saw
really unsure about whether they should
say something in this meeting well they
should just sit there
and he's really brought home there was
some demonstration in the US a year or
so ago and there was this white man on
it holding of a placard saying I was
going to write a placard but I thought
it was we've heard not from white men so
I won't that was which is which I
thought well anything else it's still a
[ __ ] plaque but it was very good it
was a very good example of how
narcissistic is because he was really
saying I'm I'm the best white person in
the world that's what he was really
saying but it's that thing of people
closed down and clam up they're not sure
what they can say and so it gives rise
to one of the great scourge ha's of our
time I mean which is self-censorship and
that uncertainty and that well can I say
this I've got white skin I was born male
am I allowed to say this or should I not
say and you think what a destructive
situation that is for us to find
ourselves in I think it also the other
side of it it's not only that it is
destructive of freedom of speech it also
really whips up this victim politics
because you have this competitive
victimhood now where everyone is trying
to demonstrate that they are greater
victims and someone else because being a
victim is now the way in which you win
social praise even in some cases
government funding you know that's the
basis on which lots of community groups
win government funding is through saying
we have all these various problems it's
the way in which you win moral authority
through being a victim whereas in the
past you might have won more authority
by demonstrating your autonomy and your
adulthood and the fact that you were
capable of governing your own life now
in a complete flip reversal you win
moral authority in 21st century Britain
by showing your wounds I'm a victim I've
had a really crap life so what that does
it encourages people to constantly
exaggerate and blow out proportion of
the problems they faced you know and so
I think there's a lot of myth making
among some of these identitarian about
how awful their lives have been I don't
buy it for a minute because they're
encouraged to do that because they need
that victim authority and also gives
rise to this incredibly divisive
competition between different groups or
we're bigger victims than you and it has
this fragmentary process even within
identity groups or even within for
example trans the trans community as
it's called even there
people will say oh but you're a white
trans person I'm a black trans person
and we have it worse than you or in the
gay community people will say oh but I'm
Muslim in gay
that's far harder than some wherever
Peter Tatchell never had to face this
kind of complete breaking apart even off
the identity groups themselves so that
you end up with all these tiny sectarian
bloc's who just are constantly fighting
for that moral high-ground of victimhood
so they can say well I'm the chief
victim therefore I deserve the money and
I deserve the newspaper column and I
deserve the sympathy so um that's really
bad and and I think it's added really
destructive impact on the new generation
in particular because I go to campuses
and speak and I constantly meet these
young people who have really plummy posh
voices and you can tell they had really
nice upbringing
and they want to convince you that they
suffer from structural oppression that
they are they face abuse and hardship
every day of their life that they are
the most downtrodden community in living
memory and you just want to shake them
say that's not true but of course what
you really should do is someone who
cares about the future of society it
should shake your project it's my
privilege and try and work out why
they're saying this why are they saying
these things which are patently untrue
and the reason they're saying them is
because identity politics encourages you
to see yourself as weak and pathetic
whereas left-wing politics in particular
but also right-wing liberal politics
used to encourage you to see yourself as
confident and capable and that shift as
always remember to subscribe to our
channel if you enjoy it and if you
already subscribed remember to click
that button next to subscribe button so
that you get notified whenever we
release a fantastic interview like this
well we are on social media so as always
follow us at trigger pod thank you again
for watching or listening and we'll see
you next week bye